after a disputed presidential election
Ebu takes the oath of office as
Nigeria's 17th leader
the problems he's promised to deal with
on his first day in office include
Insurgency banditry and economic
slowdown kidnappings and a secessionist
movement we shall defend the nation
from Terror
and all from above
criminology that threatened
prepares it is a stability
of our partner
remodel our economy
to bring our growth
and develop the GDP much better than we
have today
I assure you he also promised to grow
the economy by six percent a year
economic stagnation with currency and
insecurity BB the main problem is
inherited as president but he's also
leading a nation deeply divided by the
previous presidential election his key
appointments and how he can unite the
Nigerians will point to how he wants to
shape this country in the coming years
and that analysee will be the first test
of his administration how he does that
within the context of the political
geography of appointments
[Music]
how do you defined by the Constitution
of this country is something else but
once he misses on that then that's a
problem an accomplished businessman
into politics and political activism is
four decades old
his chance to prove his political
argument came when in 1999 he was
elected governor of Nigeria's business
Capital Lagos for eight years
is credited with setting the state on a
path of economic growth despite running
battles rather than federal government
tinubu promises an open government
our Administration
will go by you only on your behalf but
never rule over you we shall consult
we shall reach out God
but never put down a single person
contrary to our own
but governing Lagos State may not be the
same as leading a complex Nation like
Nigeria and many people are expecting a
lot
new jobs
for everyone and the kind of
a country where is Unified foreign
exchange if that can be I just said
quickly you know the usual Water Shelter
transportation and of course the power
supply
he's supposed to say his previous
experience has prepared him to lead
Nigeria
to do that he must first defeat his
presidential opponents in the courts
while his election Victory is being
challenged Ahmed Idris Al Jazeera